Drake is shooting down his dad's claim
that Drake's
only calls him an accident or the sake
of his music Dennis Graham says that
he's been very present in his son's life
and Drake's criticism of his parenting
is just to sell records that's a Drake
wrote on his Instagram story woke up
today so hurt man my father will say
anything to anyone that's willing to
listen to him it's sad when family gets
like this what can we really do that's
the people we were stuck with every bar
I ever spit was the truth and the truth
that's hard for some people to accept
now this comes after what his dad said
in an interview with power 106 lesson
Los Angeles I expect of life I never hid
anything from him I never kept anything
from I took him down through there and I
showed him this side of life I showed
him that side of life we he's always
been around music I I had a conversation
with Drake about that I have always been
with Drake hmm I talked to him if not
every day every other day Wow
and we we really got into a deep
conversation about that I said great why
are you saying all this different stuff
about me man like this is not cool
dad it sells records why is he calling
him Drake Drake that's weird right there
is weird
well Traci and Nora are wondering about
his state in that interview ah baby's a
little maybe maybe maybe maybe
but unlike hoody like who do you believe
in this oh I I mean I believe Drake I
think that's always in the limelight
he's always trying to find his way to
the camera I I think he's releasing
music on his own right now Drake's a
great singer and his lyrics are amazing
and I think he's telling the truth
I think we need to interview his mom and
see what she thinks of of this whole
thing that that's the thing like Drake
is so close to his mom he's not as
always around but we don't really see I
can't really think of a circumstance
where I've seen ya Drake and his dad
together I think maybe Dennis's
perspective like being around for his he
says you talk to him on the phone like
maybe every other day right like that's
very different from actually being there
being this life and maybe that's Drake's
perspective too like when you're young
kid and your dad's not around I find it
so interesting to you like obviously now
Drake is a father and we know that
situation is a little bit so like this
Drake feel like he's a present dad I
don't know oh he's turning around the
world so yeah yeah he can't be there all
the time either with his son right so
you just wonder yeah it's just
interesting how his dad had to talk
about it there's absolutely no reason to
bring it up right I mean this is his
son's career that he's kind of talking
about and I don't what's his benefit for
him to say that out there and was
clearing his name I'm not sure if that's
the thing he wants to do but at this
point though foster says that man is
wearing an oval like oh yeah yeah oh
great stuff yes is that an artist yeah
he's always done music and handsome
acting along the ways but leasing new
music to like think yeah Kate says
sounds like he's taking credit for
Drake's success in some way but also his
dad's claims could be told in huge it he
says that Drake has always been talking
about his dad in his music maybe they're
both right even though you're there
you're not they're just yeah it might be
someone's to perspective right like you
think you're there like we're saying
just like but then you're only you're
only talking to him but he also mentions
the fact that they in that interview
that they actually had a heart-to-heart
conversation about this right so I mean
if they had that conversation hey Dad
listen you you think you were there but
you weren't really there for me
right and he must have said you know I
felt like I was there for you and he
still talked about it the way he did
well and it's gonna be with both those
perspectives like yeah I felt like
you're really there and maybe I
shouldn't be putting this on music but
yeah people it appeals to people I guess
people enjoy me
you read this stuff yeah it's the
interesting relationship okay publicity
for we're talking about today